what's up CH it's your boy Travis back
but 12 you know how get yeah hope yall
doing good hope you having a blessed day
y being safe having a great day
today I ain't been doing nothing bro I
just been playing the game for real
welcome to the screen though this crazy
weekend in championship football and big
decisions was a crazy weekend let's get
into it what I've been up to playing a
video game cleaning up the house you see
the room look a lot more nicer see back
there right there on the on the on my
little desk right there yeah I cleaned
that up changed it all Christmas stuff
probably can't see it very well but yeah
change the Christmas stuff in my YouTube
plat it stayed up there but yeah why
didn't silver it's room I need to change
the bed pillows I'mma do that yeah I
done clean up the room a lot getting
everything everything
ready yeah I had to clean up the place
man clean the garage garage I'm clean up
everything just to make sure everything
look nice for Christmas I have time I
can just stay home
clean play the video game chill Le on
yeah go to the gym I've been going to
the gym too I just came back from the
gym yeah I'm been going to the
gym every morning with lyanna Monday
through Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
is all weekend but other than
that nothing for real but yeah it's a
crazy weekend it's been crazy
y'all it's been crazy dunk is
crazy to Deion said what's up all right
I got
you all right now it's time for
overreaction not
overreaction from the past week so let's
get right into it SC football playoffs
are set Michigan Washington Texas
Alabama the playoff committee got it
right what y'all think chat hey I don't
know how you can go undefeated and still
don't be in there so I don't know what
to say just cuz you lost a player don't
mean anything I don't know if they got
it right what youall think y think they
got it right no you just W undefeated
for nothing literally no reason and you
beat two rank teams so or was it two
rank teams or three rank teams I don't
remember but yeah yeah I don't know I
don't know how you can go undefeated and
then just get kicked out of C playoffs
and that's what we all playing for to
being the playoffs to winning
Championship but yeah all right
hey overreaction definitely didn't get
it right
next I'm so much in so much disbelief
right
now yeah
bro and Jordan Char is trying to stand
on business but they already made their
PL they already did what they did so hey
it's not overreaction bro they deserve
it it deserve to be in there they want
undefeated 13
and0 for no reason that's crazy
but hey last year they put a team in
there didn't say nothing about it now
they don't they take a team out that
deserve to be in it so I don't
know Jo TR is
right no I wish he did never break his
leg
but what we got
next Georgia should be harder than six I
don't know Georgia is a top ranked team
and they're a good team but hey that's
what I'm saying though like you say
Georgia is not
a not a top Frank not a uh not one of
the best four teams how is that even
possible you take FL stay out and then
you say George is not even
a top one of the top teams and they lost
to good Alabama team Alabama had a good
night what else you want them to do
about that they
play Alabama lost to
Texas Alabama and Texas in
it so I don't get that
cuz Hey Georgia is definitely a top
ranked team
but you can't make everybody happy
so you should have just did an emergency
6 T
bro what we got
next not
overreaction Michigan SK
Alabama Michigan SK Alabama bro scared
of Alabama bro yeah Florida state was
undefeated and not a top rank team one
of the top four teams Georgia lost to
Alabama by what three points and still
not a top ranked team after going
undefeated until they played them so F
it's you got SC Georgia got
scammed hey F you play elementary
schools so what about Georgia then okay
got nothing else to say about that all
right yeah next that's reaction I mean I
over
actually big man TD housing f is epic
not a reaction that's
fine bro what taking a bite out
whaty heck no are them germs on that jum
I'm
good oh I'm
good
hey not reaction that boy holding him
back I know he was getting all type of
cuss words throwing at him I would have
been so mad but I'm hey he doing his job
that's what he supposed to
do but did he job SK that's no not
overreaction he did his job supposed to
do yeah I see it see Mr do came back and
still called him that boy is fast he DK
M out that boy DK H
him H them H
them getting hawked is crazy though
that's Defence of a hustle yeah yes sir
not open reaction definitely was
next yeah I supposed to be on top of
that
hey not reaction definitely need to be
me what we got
next take with the big 12 Championship
MVP that
hard for the chill W not over reaction
it is I used to watch WWE all the time
next this is not too much bro what is
this
bro playing a game on a basketball court
screen
oh n that's not doing too much of
reaction that's not doing too much
that's doing just right why trying to
watch that
jump hey gotta watch wherever you at
jayen Daniels is the hinsman hey I don't
know who going to be the hman but since
Florida State got k out it should be
Jordan Travis cuz they just got robbed
you going to rob him again oh Dam you
got Jord Travis in there
yeah yeah buddy it's jayen Daniels it's
Jayden Daniels for sure yeah it's Jayden
Daniels bro why didn't pay his
interceptions on there though it's all
good yeah J D goingon to win that enough
time on that next thing we got today we
already talked about Florida state to
Florida State be in the college football
playoffs chat rate pull up yes see I'm
telling you bro people just people that
say no just get a FSU like what are yall
scared for all right p over with Let's
Get Right Next all right this is Scot
bracket predictions who you think going
to win so let's get right into it
Michigan Alabama who you think GNA
win I don't know bro Michigan playing
good and Michigan got defense Alabama
been Play Good Alabama got a D
hey y thing going win man I'm going with
the chat on this
one yeah if I was s to stay I boycot the
game versus Georgia too ain't no reason
to play you just play all those games
for nothing
Michigan hey
Michigan it's going to be BMA but
Michigan cuz chat say
Michigan all right Mission going in
Washington Texas who y think going
WI that's going to be a good
game yeah I got to go my conference I
got to go with a Pack 12 you know I had
to go my com sh man Washington man
Washington it's going to be Washington
to Michigan and the B who I think going
win
though
sh Wasington man I'm going to
washingt I think Alabama going to go all
the way though I'm going say Washington
for now cuz I got to go in my conference
bro Pack 12 got to stand up with the
guys watch this national champs all
right next play a game called b or BS I
need to get 10 cor RCT to win I'm going
to need your
help let's go
chat now it's B of BS first bowl game
Crick acceleration bow yes that's a
bow chees a bow yes that's a
bow hey chat help me out what's is this
a bow is this a bow help me out chat
this a b this a ball this a ball this a
ball this a ball this a bow this a ball
it's a ball this a ball no no no no no
no no not a
ball wait it said
yes oh it's
no chat stop trolling bro roofclaim.com
that's a bow I never heard of that no
that's not a
bow no heard of that one I a heard of
that one
y'all that's a bow I never heard of that
bow all right next Hot Pocket ball bro
ain't no such thing as no Hot Pocket
ball
no is this a bow y is this a bow chat CH
help me out bro all right no it's not a
bow bro y'all say no yes I'm
lost oh it is a bow okay what are your
plant bow no that's not a
bow the next one yes the
ball how many you got right six now it's
time for the hard ones this one sound
like it's a bow I'm going go with a bow
it's a bow
again Lucky Charms no I a heard of no
Lucky Charms but I'm trying to play
that need that seral how many I got
right how many I got right how many I
got right I only missed two eight right
oh I got to get two more
right I could just say oh yes and then I
can get it
right easy Bak oven bowl no that's not a
bowl I knew that wasn't a bow yes that's
a
bow bad boy MBO no that's not a bow
that's not a bow yes that's a bow the
last one is a bowl the other two not a
that's a bowl 20 T is not a bow game
bro how is this a bow bro all right but
I don't know this last one
bro really saying all these are b games
bro bro what is this Gabby gold bro yes
that's a bowl bro forget that junk I
don't know m
Max B no
bro I want chat y know I get I'm like
that stand on
business mus City
B we just naming BS bro none of jump was
BS for real bro anotherone jump was the
BS the male B yeah I know after all
these BS and playoffs y'all know what's
happening in draft so I'm going to give
you my first top five picks NFL Draft G
to the spring so let's get right into
boy number one is either going to be
Caleb Williams or Marvin Harrison I say
Caleb wait did the be see the
quarterback for nah the Bears can't get
kale Williams bro see gonna be the
Patriots or the Cardinals that g him no
not the Cardinals Patriots or commanders
first pick I think Marvin Harrison then
the be pick up Marvin Harrison
first bar Bowers I forgot about B bers
Patriots love tight ends too Patriots do
got M Jones too
Bears ah
ah
uh oh my God no
way I think Kay is gonna go to uh patri
for sure if him is going to be switched
he GNA go first then Mar gonna go second
you never
know but yeah Patriots killer wins we do
got Dallas Turner in here got Dallas
Turner we
got what does the Cardinal need
though Cardinal gonna pick something
they need right wouldn't they pick
something they need Cardinal in the o
line Carline all right we're gonna go
with uh AA F Fu I don't know how to say
his
name I know I say his name but Penn
State bro Penn State dude bro all right
now it's started getting any gritty
St get need gry yeah bro number three I
don't know I said that
D they need that from Penn State cardal
is Brock bars definitely going number
four or number five so I'm going say
Brock barers what else does the bear
need the Bears love to get defense too
so ID probably say that uh that
definitely be Dallas Turner bro I'm
going Dallas Turner number five bro bear
love getting
D
there de going crazy house all right
chat that's the end of
this season one with 12
talks this the end of season one 12
talks man see y'all when I see y'all hey
it's been strong 15 weeks hey y'all can
catch me on Twitch later tonight though
d h go tip y know y' can catch me there
I'll be on later tonight playing Call of
Duty not wait Call of Duty come out yeah
Call of
Duty 2K fortnite I be playing all the
games pranks and everything hey nice
seeing y'all nice meeting y'all thank
y'all for tuning in with the show y can
catch your boy on Twitch db3 tip hey
this the end of 12 talks see y'all next
season we have a next season love y'all
peace out thank y'all see y'all next
[Music]
time